congratulations professor Allison well
thank you very much and you just
received the Nobel Prize how was the
ceremony that was bitter spectacular it
was you know just the king there now the
presentations in myself was was was very
cool but made even cooler is the person
who awarded a member of the community
class J who gave the cancer we gave ours
had a clever way of working a sort of
musical he's going into it was a simple
song at first before their work and then
afterwards you're a powerful you have
made quite a scientific journey you
started with pure curiosity and
continued your research all the tricky
way to a medicine that now cure people
from deadly diseases that must be such a
special privilege it is I think it's
something that did I think every
everybody who does basic science would
dream of you know doing something and
really having at work out to help people
but it's so arduous and the path so long
and you know then getting it from a
finding into a drug you know or
something is pretty hard but you know
this there's something worth it I mean
it's one thing to have successful
experiments to learn something new and
that's worth that's worth a lot to me it
was always when I was doing science
trying to solve an issue that was all I
was doing you know we've got to figure
this out you know but then it at one
point you know every now and then I
would say okay what do we know now what
how could we use this inside sort of
work then try to jump you know and say
okay can we use this to treat cancer you
don't have thought of a Federal Way
thought of the implications of the basic
science and
it all worked out and it has also been
important to you to meet with people
that got cured by this treatment and for
them you're sort of everything what what
do they mean to you you know several
years ago not syllabus about four years
or so before I met the first patient and
I actually we've become good friends and
she's very young she was 22 and she was
diagnosed with metastatic melanoma I was
told she was Hospice bound and now she
has two kids that are approaching their
teenage years and she's here tonight
she's here tonight yes and I was a
spiritual moment to me when I first met
her and just I don't know it just things
happened in my head I thought wow
there's just some just some product you
know it's not just numbers on a graph
you know huh they like that it's a real
person whose life is you know she's able
to live her life and so I love I love
meeting the patients to kind of get
emotional about it sometimes but you
know one of the things that I think that
I hope the the publicity that companies
the Nobel Prize will do is is give
people hope you know civil realized that
cancer isn't necessarily that diagnosis
of cancer isn't necessarily a death
sentence and there are things that can
be done and also I hope will help get
people a volunteer to be in clinical
trials so we can keep the work going and
improve what we're doing now now a big
part of the research is done the medal
is in your pockets and now you're going
to enjoy this very Swedish party is
there anything special that you're
looking forward to this evening I think
well I've heard so many things about it
from some of my friends that have been
to it and the the dinner and how grand
it is dancing and then
everybody says the after-party is this
really good one so looking forward to
that still around have a great evening
professor thank you very much